o nome modais de falar sobre como se
sente rico em quatro passos de onde veio
a idéia de onde de como se sentir rico
em quatro passos disso o economista é
como os ossos do ofício como os ossos do
ofício
eu escuto mundo seguintes perguntas é
esse jejum teve o primeiro milhão ou
como é que as pessoas fazem para se
sentir ricas como eu faço para me sentir
rico e essas perguntas elas eram tão
freqüentes que comecei a me perguntar o
que significava ser rico
olha no dicionário e observei que ser
rico significa acumular muito dinheiro
ter muitas posses e muitos bens mas é um
conceito que não deixava muito
confortável o conceito de pensar que ser
rico é acumular dinheiro foi perguntar
algumas pessoas há nesse caso mais de
500 pessoas o que elas achavam como ela
define um ser rico ea segunda pergunta
era se elas se sentiam ricas para minha
surpresa as pessoas elas cá com elas
concordavam de que ser rico significava
acumula riqueza e que não as pessoas não
se sentiam ricas
observando essas características eu
comecei a pensar em quais seriam os
quatro passos que a gente poderia
estabelecer que as pessoas de fato se
sentissem ricas e aí o passo 01 que eu
digo a vocês é que a gente tem de
trabalhar para viver e não viver para
trabalhar e neste caso aqui eu queria
dar dois exemplos que eu ouvi
recentemente
primeiro era de um pai que veio se
queixar de que foi tava conversando com
os filhos e os perguntando para os
filhos quais eram as memórias que eles
tinham da infância de quando eles
brincavam juntos e para a tristeza do
pai os filhos disseram que em nenhum
momento da infância eles lembravam do
pai junto que todas as lembranças que
eles tinham do durante a infância
estavam sempre associadas à avó e aí a
segunda o segundo o depoimento que houve
que me causou ainda mais tristeza foi de
uma mãe de um filho viciado em crack
que era mãe solteira e que começou a
explicar que o pela sua situação
ela tinha que sair mundos e de casa e
acaba chegando muito tarde
nesse meio termo o filho dela se viciou
entrou num problema muito grande e ela
chegou concluiu quique eu lutei a vida
inteira para que nada faltasse pro meu
filho mas eu esqueci o mais fundamental
que ser mãe ou mãe é de graça
então quando olha esses dois exemplos
eu começo a pensar que a gente tem que
repensar nossas relações com dinheiro e
consumo porque toda vez que o consumo
alguma coisa eu estou necessariamente
abrindo mão de ter mais tempo com a
minha família
então não existe escolha sem renúncia eu
estou escolhendo eu estou renunciando
esses pontos me levam a pensar no
segundo o placar no segundo passo pra me
sentir mais rica eu preciso me desapegar
das coisas e eu preciso me desapegar das
pessoas empregadas as coisas porque a
relação é simples
vai ter sempre alguém em uma situação
melhor do que a minha
sempre não existe ser humano que sinta
pleno e máximo
eu sei que vou achar alguém que em algum
bom tu é melhor que eu esse eu continuo
me comparando o tempo inteiro com outras
pessoas
eu sempre vou me sentir pobre e eu
sempre vou me sentir fracassado então eu
me começa a pensar em cada vez que eu me
sinto pobre fracassado eu lembre o que
me trouxe até aqui porque eu tenho
história pra contar
eu tenho isso e as pessoas têm que
entender que as pessoas estão
interessadas nas minhas histórias
as pessoas não estão interessadas nas
coisas que eu acumulei então eu preciso
me desapegar dessas idéias
a terceira o terceiro passo pra gente se
sentir rico é ter tempo pra dar
tempo e aqui eu queria dar dois exemplos
que eu vivi nos últimos anos que me
reforçaram o conceito de riqueza
primeiro exemplo era de uma consultoria
financeira que eu sozinho que tinha como
missão receber clientes e os clientes
tinham uma hora para dar um problema
financeiro a gente chegar a uma solução
financeira
um belo dia chegou uma senhora e ela
passou 60 minutos sem parar falando
senão ela não falava de um problema
financeiro ela falava de problemas do
ser feminino era o marido eram as contas
era o trabalho eram os filhos e por mais
que eu tentasse intervir para ajudar
aquela pessoa só queria ser ouvida
segundo exemplo foi um exemplo que eu
vivi aqui há uns dois anos
toda vez que determinava que terminou
por volta de dez da noite é tomar um
belo dia chegou um funcionário da
operação e disse você pode entrar nesse
texto
era um texto em inglês é relativamente
simples e que eu traduzi pra ele e
depois desse dia ele começou a se
encontrar
freqüentemente todo fim de ano
pra começar sob os mais variados temas
em inglês eram as cores eram os números
eram uma letra de música e aí um belo
dia ele fez professora eu aprendi uma
frase nova eu queria escrever aqui no
quadro e escreveu esse texto aqui nós
podemos mudar o mundo e era um texto que
me causou muito impacto porque naquela
hora eu entendi bem o terceiro passo por
mais dinheiro que eu tivesse não era
dinheiro que aquelas duas pessoas
estavam interessadas
elas estavam interessadas no meu tempo e
tempo eu tinha pra dar então terceiro
passo para se sentir rico é ter tempo
pra dar tempo
o último passo que eu acho que é a
consolidação desses três últimos em
viagem viajar é uma coisa extremamente
prazerosa e eu queria começar a falar um
dia de viagem em cima de um trecho de um
filme chamado curioso caso de benjamin
button em que ele escreve para filha
eu espero que você veja coisas que
surpreenda você e aí o conceito de
viajar ele é tão importante porque ele é
assim a síntese dos três últimos passos
para que eu viaje eu preciso me
desapegar não só das minhas coisas mas
os meus conceitos que são sempre tão
rígidos para que eu viaje eu preciso ter
tempo para me abrir para o novo e
finalmente para que eu viaje eu preciso
entender que viajar me diz que trabalho
não é tudo mais
além do trabalho e aí dentro dessa
lógica a parte boa de viajar é que
viajar é um conceito muito amplo
eu posso viajar significa sair de um
canto para outro
então eu viajo quando eu saio do país
eu viajo quando eu conheço interior do
estado e eu viajo quando eu vou dentro
de mim
e dentro das viagens que eu fiz tive o
prazer de conhecer 37 países
a viagem mais interessantes que eu fiz
depois da recomendação de algumas
pessoas foi mergulhar dentro foi viajar
pra dentro
e aí compartilhando das idéias das
pessoas
eu observei que quando a gente viaja pra
dentro a gente encontra um tempo imenso
dentro de nós a gente contra um templo
grande que nos faz mais fortes mais
felizes e muito mais ricos
a definição de que acumular riqueza é
rico é uma definição dada pelo
dicionário que pergunta vocês é qual é a
sua definição de ser rico
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]